[Музика]
привіт учні 9 класу і ласкаво просимо на
урок англійської,
мене звуть Анна, і сьогодні
ми продовжимо нашу тему спрощеного способу життя молоді
- Wata Anna - це демонстраційне
шоу Hajima Frodo на зараз у mo buddha
mahavira для популяризації  Додатковий da da da
Pete дозволив Кім так молодіжний спосіб життя, Джаред,
ми поговоримо про граматику
трохи пізніше, а тепер давайте подумаємо про
щось, що насправді дуже близьке
кожному з вас, тому, оскільки у ваших
підлітків, звичайно, є хороші та погані
все було єдиним, тож які вони,
подивіться на екран, які
переваги та недоліки бути
підлітком,
що в цьому добре
Що може бути плюсами підлітка
чи мінусами бути підлітком, ви можете скласти
свій власний список принаймні 3 пунктів
переваг і принаймні 3 недоліків
oj0 так Вася
Олена анотація коли проти  ite of
lastness Busiek parivar billet gift i if
Nick Nadal EQ shutter cohosh aho повинен
завантажити повторювану комерційну рекламу Honda
за півдолару Buddha pendulum nappa sheet
of lastness bicycle, тому таймер на одну хвилину
ввімкнено
[Музика]
добре, тепер давайте візьмемо  подивіться на екран,
і тепер ви можете побачити мій власний список
переваг і недоліків. Я був
підлітком, оскільки ви бачите, що я маю більше
трьох балів у кожній категорії, тому давайте
спочатку подивимося на переваги, тож які переваги
є  бути підлітком
молодим це перша перевага
ти молодий ти красивий ти
дуже жвавий, тож це, мабуть, найкраща
перевага бути підлітком наступна
, коли ти молодий, у тебе багато
енергії, тому ти готовий до  робити багато
речей, і у вас є сила, і у вас є
сила, і у вас є енергія, щоб робити
ці речі, так що це другий,
а третій підлітки
зазвичай дуже креативні, вони не
обмежені різними фіксованими мисленнями і
так далі.  o вони дозволяють своїй творчості проявити максимум своєї творчості. У
підлітковому віці у вас
є багато можливостей, ви можете зробити
багато речей, ви можете спробувати багато речей,
і, звичайно, вас не звинувачують у
цьому і ви не візьмете багато
відповідальність за виконання цих
речей ще одна перевага –
дружба, як правило, підлітки досить
дружні, і у віці 13 15 16 років ви
отримуєте нових друзів
або стаєте ближчими друзями з
людьми, яких ви вже знаєте, тож це
переваги підліткового віку  Звичайно,
це не єдині переваги, якщо у вас
є деякі додаткові у вашому списку, це
дуже добре,
тепер давайте перейдемо до недоліків,
які погані речі не дуже хороші
в тому, щоб бути підлітком, тому перше
, що у вас є багато домашніх завдань, тому
замість цього  виходячи з друзями,
ви повинні сидіти вдома робити домашнє завдання, у
вас багато завдань, які потрібно закінчити,
тому багато завдань потрібно зробити,
і так, багато домашніх завдань є
недоліком бути підлітком  одна з
головних наступна одна маленька
свобода у підлітковому віці у вас не вистачає свободи
зазвичай у вас є батьки, які говорять
вам, що робити, куди йти, що не
робити, куди не йти,
так що так, це, мабуть, величезний
недолік  Будучи підлітком, ви
не можете самостійно вирішувати багато
речей щодо малого вільного часу, який насправді
пов’язаний з домашнім завданням і, можливо, деякими
домашніми справами, які, наприклад,
кажуть вам батьки або просять вас допомогти з
домашнім господарством тощо, і у вас є домашнє
завдання для цього  звичайно, це
зменшує час, який ви можете витрачати на те, щоб
розвиватися різними способами,
виходячи на вулицю, слухаючи музику,
читаючи літературу та багато інших речей,
які можуть бути вам цікавими, інше
, багато стресу, так, життя підлітків
дуже напружене, у вас є багато
що потрібно зробити, у вас є багато
справ, які потрібно зробити, у вас є
друзі, можливо, у вас є хлопець чи
дівчина, а потім у вас так багато
емоцій, і ви стаєте  такий стрес,
так багато стресу - це величезний
недолік бути підлітком
ще одна річ відсутність досвіду
іноді, коли вам доводиться самостійно вирішувати,
що робити чи ні, що не
робити, у вас недостатньо досвіду, щоб
проаналізувати, що слід робити  що
не слід робити, так
, це також недолік, звичайно, якщо у
вас є хороші друзі,
які мають достатньо досвіду, або якщо у вас
є інші люди, до яких можна звертатися
, було б добре, якщо це батьки,
тож, звичайно, ви можете звернутися до
них  і попросіть їх про допомогу, зараз ми
збираємося читати і слухати діалог
між двома друзями,
один з них спробував дуже цікаву
діяльність, яку вони ніколи раніше не пробували, тому
подивіться на екран, слухайте і читайте, тож у
нас є двоє людей, Джон і  Елісон,
і давайте почнемо читати Джона Вау,
це було дивовижно, я не можу повірити, що я щойно
зробив це, Елісон також не можу, я був настільки
наляканий, що ледве міг дивитися на тебе,
сподіваюся, ти зробиш багато фотографій, звичайно,
я зробив, але я не впевнений, що там  буде
добре, мої руки тремтіли, не заважай,
наступного разу ти можеш зробити кращі знімки наступного разу,
Джон, ти жартуєш, не кажи
мені, що стрибки з парашутом будуть твоїм новим
хобі, якщо я думаю, що ти
неймовірний, ти був наляканий  перед тим, як
ти сів у літак, я знаю, але це
було частиною гострих відчуттів, чому б тобі не спробувати
, о ні, дякую, я б краще залишився на
твердій землі, якщо ти не проти,
зараз, коли ми читаємо та слухаємо
діалог  давайте подивимося на основні
моменти, тут є два друзі Джон
і Елісон і Джон спробували новий вид
діяльності, що це за заняття, ви
пам'ятаєте, звичайно, стрибки з парашутом
добре, чи подобається Елісон, Елісон, здається
, дуже розгублена, коли вона дивилася на
Джона  стрибки з парашутом вона мала зробити
багато фотографій добре давайте перевіримо, наскільки
добре ви пам'ятаєте факти з
діалогу, який ви щойно прочитали
неприємно, ви повинні сказати
, правдиві ці твердження чи хибні давайте
поглянемо на перше речення хлопчик
не виконав вправу, він не виконав
так чи правильно відповідно до діалогу,
що він
не виконував вправу, він не
стрибнув з парашутом, і насправді він не виконав, що
ви пам'ятаєте з тексту, що
ви пам'ятаєте з діалогового вікна  добре,
ми можемо пам'ятати, що він насправді це зробив,
тому це має бути помилка номер два,
яку дівчина сфотографувала, але вона подумала,
що всі вони були поганої якості, це
твердження правдиво чи неправда,
що ви пам'ятаєте, вона насправді сказала,
що її руки тремтіли так  правда це
чи неправда, ви думаєте, зараз
ми перевіримо в кінці, а тепер давайте
подивимося на третій,
друг хлопчика сподівається, що Джон
захопиться стрибками з парашутом,
пам'ятаєте, що Еллісон сказав
Джону про стрибки з парашутом  вона заохочувала
його зайнятися цим як новим хобі
прямо чи неправда у ваших підручниках,
а четвертий друг Джона не
має бажання спробувати стрибки з парашутом,
правда чи неправда, Еллісон хотіла спробувати
стрибки з парашутом самостійно  вона зникає  t
спробувати це самостійно, тож як ви думаєте
, що це правда чи неправда, добре тепер, коли ви
маєте відповіді у своїх підручниках,
давайте перевіримо відповіді, щоб перше
твердження було хибним, хлопчик виконував
вправу, Скотт, він стрибнув з парашутом
номер два  правда, Еллісон робила
знімки, але вона насправді боялася,
що вони поганої якості, тому що
її руки тремтіли
номер три, це неправда Еллісон сподівається, що
Джон не буде займатися стрибками з парашутом як
хобі
номер чотири. Друг Джона не має
бажання  спробуйте стрибки з парашутом, тому Еллісон сказала, що
вона не хотіла цього робити, вона взагалі не
хотіла пробувати стрибки з парашутом, тому це
твердження вірне, добре зроблено, тепер
давайте ще раз подивимося на діалог,
тут ви можете побачити підкреслені фрази,
які  фактично підтримують попередні
твердження, чи є вони правдивими чи
хибними, щоб ви могли знайти інформацію
для попередньої вправи в
підкресленій частині діалогу.
d ви
помітили підкреслені частини, давайте перейдемо
до наступної частини. Ось слова,
виділені жирним шрифтом у діалозі, чим вони відрізняються,
що у них спільного,
давайте подивимося, у нас є кілька
речень, у яких слова
виділено жирним шрифтом
jemima red Shinya ти кидаєш славу ми
Delaney, твоє ім'я ricktum скажемо, що якась
ідеологічна місія є та, яку Atala
виконує місцеве вибілювання з Ланою гроші,
жодні заручники не можуть забезпечити Hoboken О,
нагадування про наймокріший nity словаччина
vigil німецькою перемикач крокомірів
щоразу  немає відповіді, я показав це
тут, розливай зараз, тож давайте подивимося
на речення, які містять ці слова,
перше, яке було дивовижним, наступне
, мої руки тремтіли, третє
речення, Джон, ти жартуєш,
а останнє не скажи  я стрибки з
парашутом стану твоїм новим хобі,
добре, тому всі ці слова мають одну
спільну рису, а саме закінчення I ng букви
в кінці кожного слова О, циган
Славе, мій собака помилково написав нарізо король Шиня
в  g the King China in so amazing
shaking kidding стрибки з парашутом збираються, але
які відмінності, якщо ви подивитеся
на слово дивовижна, яка частина мови
є this it's прикметник so pragmatic
another one shaking is it adjective
no тут це дієслово в  безперервна
форма О Джефф Данхем про лавовий жезл Божої Індії
для мене як минуле безперервне, що ми
вже вивчили з вами наступне,
ви жартуєте, це теперішнє
безперервне це також дієслово в
безперервній формі oh just attach the
pradosham uniform in the  наступне слово —
стрибки з парашутом — добре, цей — не
прикметник
цей — не суцільна форма це
— іменник словацька парашутний стрибок вул.  amant,
а потім у нас буде словосполучення,
і тут це неперервна форма
слова, тому going це дієслово з ing
okay, на чому ми сьогодні зосередимося
, це іменник із закінченням ing, який
зазвичай називається герундієм Oh je  Мінетті,
добре, Майя — король молодший, тепер зрозумійте,
чому це герундій вище її власної G, тож, як
ви бачите, герундій — це іменник
, утворений від дієслова шляхом додавання ing, і тут
це трохи схоже на математику, ви
повинні прийняти дієслово за  приклад для
читання, потім ви додаєте ing,
а потім ви отримуєте це слово для
читання або Jemima в'язниця або derecho home
window DMS продовження ing сказав так Louis
ta Amanda nakum wow, як це може ст
тися насправді закінчення в ing допомагає нам зр
бити це тут  Ви також можете побачити деякі
приклади того, як іменники ing можуть використовуватися в
англійській мові, читання допомагає вам вивчати англійську,
її улюблене хобі – читання. Я люблю
читати, тому, як ви бачите, герундій або
іменник ing можуть бути на початку
речення, а також у  кінець це
добре, тепер давайте візьмемо a  подивіться на слова
тут, що нам потрібно зробити
з них форми герундію, тому зробіть герундій,
використовуючи ing Vitis robo-moe для
махараджі, сховище кольорів – король-
молодший, тому тут у нас є слова, які
можна співати, щоб написати, щоб розмахувати  вчитися
бігти подорожувати в магазин усі ці
слова дієслова бюджетні місця це Слава сказати
геній лава ято рибапод беретта її
Ong dr.  Eman точний двигун він ing зараз
я не дитина, не тато, серйозно, точний
другий, Jeannie ing це досить легко, тож
давайте подивимося на екран
перше слово, яке потрібно заспівати, тоді ми повинні будемо
співати праворуч,
ми додаємо ing і отримуємо плату за написання
зверніть увагу, що ми пропустили букву E і
є WRIT і G або J книга wa e
NOS dejas lava will padilla to swim, нам
потрібно додати ing, а потім ми отримаємо
плавати. Зверніть увагу, що в
цьому слові є mm наступне, яке потрібно вивчити  нам
потрібно додати ing, а потім ми вчимося добре,
наступний для виконання, якщо ми додаємо ing ми отримуємо
біг, зверніть увагу на подвійне n в
середині слова наступне, щоб
подорожувати, нам потрібно додати ing і тоді ми
отримуємо подорожі Double  L перед закінченням ing
і останнім, хто буде робити покупки тут, у нас
також буде подвійна літера в кінці
магазину,
ми подвіймо літеру P, а потім ми отримаємо
покупки
, додавши ing okay good Сподіваюся, тепер
ви розумієте структуру того, як ми
робимо  дієслова стають іменниками, додаючи ing,
а тепер візьмемо a  подивіться на екран
ще раз, тут ви можете побачити слова
, за якими зазвичай слідує герундій О
Дженна Хурана Візеріс бюджет поцілунок лава
горох відьма Лукаса тепер це наш єдиний
доктор.  slovis the kimchi
ing що ключова слов'янська неприязнь насолоджуюся
ненавистю обожнюю любов фантазії, як нелюбов і
розум, тому їх називають словами симпатії
та нелюбові top tes lava chemical
Estonia taavi має покрити це захист
я вибираю, але більше, це про Napa
дебати добре, тепер давайте  подумайте, що нам
подобається, а що не подобається, то що вам
подобається чи не подобається, складіть власні
речення, використовуючи фрази, наведені нижче, я
почну, тому перший, хто їсть
морозиво,
особисто я ненавиджу їсти морозиво Я
не любитель його слухати  до музики я
люблю слухати музику я люблю
слухати різні стилі музики
насправді наступний добре робити домашнє завдання II не
можу сказати, що я ненавидів робити домашнє завдання, коли я
був студентом, але я не можу сказати, що мені
це дуже сподобалося, тому я  не любив
робити домашнє завдання, коли я був студентом
співати о, я обожнюю співати співати –
одне з моїх улюблених занять плавання
, це також те, що я не проти
робити, коли на вулиці тепло або коли
є басейн не  арбі добре і
подорожувати Я думаю, що всі люблять
подорожувати особисто я люблю це добре, хто
не любить подорожувати, покажи мені цю
людину добре, тепер твоя черга скласти
ці речення, у вас є одна хвилина, щоб
скласти три речення, використовуючи ці фрази
та слова зліва
О  Анотація лиходія Джо Сара Цубаса
навпроти дерева праворуч Джина вокалістка
увертюра любий Слава печінка груди NK
cart Mk II замерз аспрова HS Тіна
[Музика] [Музика]
добре, тож тепер давайте потренуємося в дієсловах
, після яких йдуть слова, у нас є
шість слів  ліворуч, що нам потрібно
буде використовувати в реченнях,
це уникайте. Мунаката рекомендуємо
рекомендувати овату Рада закінчити Java
Swati, обговоріть о, хлопчик, що тіло міс суми
відчуває себе як гепард,
тому ці дієслова зазвичай супроводжуються
іншим словом, тож якщо ви  хочу
сказати, що ви рекомендуєте те, що ви
повинні сказати я рекомендую піти в
кіно не я рекомендую піти не я
рекомендую піти, але я рекомендую піти
в кіно добре, ви збираєтеся  подивіться
ці слова у вправі в
наступних реченнях, давайте почнемо з
першого, ми маємо вибрати правильний
варіант начос вамос Джосії Дададжі,
брате, нишпоріть у варіанті м’ясного
павільйону перше речення вони уникали
удару Гаріна B, щоб отримати удар
як  за дієсловом уникати слід ing.
Це досить легко зрозуміти, що нам потрібно
використовувати a they уникали get in hit наступне
речення він дійсно рекомендує переходити на
футбольні ігри бути ходити на футбольні
матчі те, що я щойно сказав про
слово рекомендую, слідує  ing, який
варіант має ing, що це a, тому ми повинні сказати, що
він дійсно рекомендує ходити на футбольні
ігри, молодці, наступний, який вона
закінчила, дивитися телевізор або дивитися телевізор,
що було б правильним варіантом, як
було б правильно сказати це
речення  вона закінчила дивитися телевізор
добре наступне речення, про яке ми обговорювали
переїзд до Нью-Йорка або переїзд до Нью-
Йорка, що цікаво, що тут А чи Б,
звичайно, ми обговорювали переїзд до Нью-
Йорка наступного сена  tence Джейн сказала мені, що вона
пропустила зустріч зі своїми друзями. B
вийти з друзями після дієслова
to miss ми зазвичай вживали ing, тому ми
скажемо, що Джейн сказала мені, що вона сумувала
погуляти з друзями, добре, і ще
один добре  Я не думаю, що мені подобається танцювати
чи танцювати, що було б правильним
варіантом тут. Я не відчуваю, що я не
думаю, що мені хочеться щось робити, тому ми
повинні сказати це добре, я не думаю, що
мені подобається танцювати  це означає, що я не
думаю, що я хочу танцювати, порівнюючи
після дієслова what we use to do
something і після feel like we use
ing я не хочу танцювати, але мені не
хочеться танцювати добре добре,
дуже приємно зараз  ваше завдання полягає в тому, щоб знайти
слова під час пошуку слів, це
дієслова, після яких стоїть ing, і
це слова, які ми щойно
обговорили з вами на сьогоднішньому уроці, тож
тепер у вас є двохвилинний таймер.
і спробуйте знайти
слова з цього лабіринту, за якими
слідує ing Я допоможу вам з першим
у  у першому рядку є слово «
не подобається», за ним йде ing, ви можете
сказати «Мені не подобається слухати гучну музику», тож
дві хвилини, щоб ви, хлопці, знайшли
слова в цій боротьбі
[Музика]
[Музика] у
вас
все в порядку, тепер ви можете перевірити  самі
слова не тільки горизонтальні, вони
також вертикальні, а їх діагональ це було
досить важко, чи не так, тому слова не
люблять уникати обожнювати закінчити фантазувати відчувати,
як рекомендувати люблю, огида, ненавиджу
та насолоджуйтеся цими словами зазвичай
слідує ing, тому ми  насолоджуємось робити
те, що ми любимо робити щось, ми
рекомендуємо щось робити або ми обговорюємо
те, що ми обговорюємо робити те, що ми обговорювали, йти
в кіно завтра, тож
вони функціонують саме так, як вони працюють
у реченнях добре,
добре зроблено зараз, настав час для
заключної частини нашої  Урок ось ваше
домашнє завдання, тому для домашнього завдання ви повинні
скласти власні речення, використовуючи
слова та фрази ліворуч, ви можете
побачити слова, за якими слід
писати слова є фантазійна ненависть  не любити
огиду уникати насолоджуватися і так далі
праворуч у вас є ідеї, які ви можете
використати після цих слів, звичайно, якщо ви
напишете власні речення, використовуючи
власні ідеї, які будуть набагато кращими,
щоб ви могли бачити фрази для правильної
гри  гітара розмовляти з другом подзвонити
бабусі й дідусеві подорожувати в Іспанію слухати
музику дивитися фільми влаштовувати пікнік читати
хорошу книгу їсти здорову їжу займатися спортом і
танцювати, тому не забувайте ставити дієслова
у правильні форми не забудьте
додати ing та  ось ваше завдання складіть
власні речення,
тому ось воно, на сьогодні наш урок
закінчено, дуже дякую і до побачення
[Музика]
ви